[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing professor horace slughorn
and his famed slug club horace slughorn
and his slug club
are best described in dumbledore's own
words
horus said dumbledore relieving harry of
the responsibility to say any of this
likes his comfort he also likes the
company the famous
the successful and the powerful he
enjoys the feeling that he influences
these people
he has never wanted to occupy the throne
himself he prefers the back seat
more room to spread out you see he used
to hand pick
favorites at hogwarts sometimes for
their ambition or their brains
sometimes for their charm or their
talent and he had an uncanny knack for
choosing those who would go on to become
outstanding in their various fields
horus formed a kind of club of his
favorites with himself at the center
making introductions forging useful
contacts between members
and always reaping some kind of benefit
in return
whether a free box of his favorite
crystallized pineapple
or the chance to recommend the next
junior member of the goblin liaison
office
essentially horus slughorn likes to pick
favorites from all of its classes
he has a keen eye to identify if someone
will go on to achieve greatness in some
capacity
and takes great pride in their
accomplishments while we are given some
indication as to who is actually in the
club in the books and films
we aren't provided with the complete
list names are mentioned and in the film
adaptation
slughorn's wall is shown where he
proudly displays the members of his club
but we want to know more in the
beginning of the half blood prince
dumbledore instructs harry to try and
become chosen by slughorn
i tell you all this dumbledore continued
not to turn you against horus
or as we must now call him professor
slughorn
but to put you on your guard he will
undoubtedly try to collect you harry
you will be the jewel of his collection
the boy who lived
or as they call you these days the
chosen one
when harry first meets slughorn slughorn
immediately mentions the similarities
between harry and his parents
slughorn then discusses harry's mother
lily and explains that she was one of
his absolute favorites
unable to contain himself any longer
slughorn directs harry towards the shelf
featuring all of his favorites all mine
each and everyone
ex-students i mean you recognize
barnabas cuff
editor of the daily prophet always takes
my owl should i wish to register an
opinion on the news of the day
jones captain of the holy head harpies
free tickets whenever i want them
of course i haven't been to a match in
some time ah yes
regulus black no doubt there is his
older brother sirius
died a few weeks ago i taught the whole
black family except sirius
it's a shame a talented boy i got
regulars when he came along
of course but i'd have liked the set the
way that slughorn discusses his students
makes it sound as though they are his
possessions however
one thing is undeniable all of them went
to achieve some sort of fame or success
without further ado here is the full
list of slughorn's favorites
in alphabetical order from slughorn's
first and second tenure
as potions master number one adrian
adrian was a student in slughorn's class
in the year 1978
during his first tenure as potions
master adrian was born in the year 1960
and maintained a good relationship with
slughorn after he graduated
from hogwarts though adrian went on to
become a successful photographer for the
daily prophet
slughorn always had higher expectations
for him number two
abraxis malfoy abraxis malfoy was a pure
blood wizard
father to lucius malfoy and grandfather
to draco malfoy
abraxas was a good friend of slughorns
and draco attempted to name drop his
grandfather's name
in an attempt to join the slug club it's
unconfirmed whether abraxas was actually
in the slug club
or if he was just friends with slughorn
number three
ambrosius flume ambrosius flume was a
british wizard and business owner
flume was the proprietor of the popular
honeyduke sweet shop
located in hogsmeade though flume ran
the shop he was not the original owner
as the shop was first opened in 1641.
honeydukes is famous for its bertie
bott's every flavor beans
among other things number four avery
was a pure blood wizard who attended
hogwarts at the same time as tom riddle
he was part of tom riddle's gang that
would eventually go on to become the
first
death eaters avery was a student of
slytherin house
and is actually pictured in the film
adaptation of the half blood prince
number 5 barnabas cuff barnabas cuff was
a pureblood wizard that became
editor-in-chief for the daily prophet
cuff was presumably the employer of
fellow slug club member
adrian in order to join the club it's
likely that cuff was either
a an exceptional student or b came from
a famous magical background
number six blaise zabini blaise zabini
was a pure blood wizard that attended
hogwarts around the same time as harry
potter
he was a member of slytherin house and
was on good terms with draco malfoy and
his gang
blaise was a quiet boy that mostly kept
himself although on various occasions
he expressed his extreme prejudice
towards muggles muggle-borns and blood
tracers
number 7 bc we see the initials bc
scribbled onto a photograph that is on
slughorn's wall of favorites
bc appears to be some sort of mountain
climber and is depicted on some sort of
a snowy mountain top
it's possible that bc may be barty
crouch junior or barty crouch senior
though it's unlikely that it would have
been the former as slughorn completely
disassociates himself from death eaters
number eight cormac mclagan cormac
mclagan is hermione's
favorite not serious cormic mcclagan is
a british pureblood wizard
and member of the mclaren family which
slughorn knew well
in the slug club slughorn and mclagan
had the following exchange
now you cormack i happen to know you see
a lot of your uncle tiberius
because he has a rather splendid picture
of the two of you hunting nog tales in
i think norfolk oh yeah that was fun
that was
we went with bertie higgs and rufus
scrimgo this was before he
became minister obviously number nine
dahlia f
dalia f is pictured on slughorn's wall
in the film adaptation of the half blood
prince
it's likely that she was an opera singer
as she is shown wearing a full viking
maiden costume in the picture on his
shelf
number 10 dirk cresswell dirk cresswell
is a muggle-born wizard that became head
of the goblin liaison office in the
ministry of magic
during the ministry takeover by lord
voldemort cresswell attempted to hide
his heritage by forging a family tree
however he was later found out cresswell
was eventually murdered by snatchers
while on the run
number 11. eldrid warple eldred warple
was a pureblood wizard
and slug club member that would go on to
become a successful writer
warple is shown in the film adaptation
of the half-blood prince at the
christmas dinner
warple was friends with a vampire named
sanguini
and wrote a book entitled blood brothers
my life amongst the vampires
number 12 flora caro flora carro was a
british witch and member of slytherin
house
though it is not explicitly stated i
would imagine that she is somehow
related to death eaters alecto
and amicus cara it's likely that flora
and her sister hestia
were members of the slug club due to
their pure blood heritage
number 13 ginny weasley ginny weasley
was a pureblood witch
and member of the weasley family the
sister to bill
charlie percy fred george and ron
ginny would go on to achieve great
things eventually becoming a
professional quidditch player
for the holy head harpies she also
married harry potter
and the pair had three children james
albus and lily
number fourteen gweneg jones gwenek
jones was a welsh witch who began
attending hogwarts in the year 1979.
gweneg is pictured on slughorn shelf in
the film adaptation of the half blood
prince
after graduating from hogwarts gwener
will go on to become the captain and
beater
of the welsh all-female quidditch team
the holy head harpies
number 15 harry potter okay you might
know this character
i'll skip the introduction but harry
easily became a member of slughorn's
club
after allowing himself to become
collected he did this by doing
exceedingly well in slughorn's potion
class
with the help of the half-blood prince's
potion book however with harry's
reputation
it's likely that slughorn would have
eventually collected him regardless
of how well he performed in the class
number 16. hermione granger
hermione was a muggle-born witch and
member of the famous trio
she was an exceptionally gifted witch
and by far the best student of her year
for this reason it was inevitable that
she would be picked up by horus for his
slug club
hermione would eventually go on to
become minister for magic
number 17 hestia carro the sister of
flora carro
and another member of the carra family
like flora
it's likely that she is somehow related
to death eaters amicus and electo carro
at the beginning of the battle of
hogwarts hestia and her sister were seen
departing to the dungeons
number 18 lestrange lestrange is another
name that we hear quite a bit
lestrange like avery is one of the
original members of tom riddle's gang
the same gang that would go on to become
death eaters lestrange is shown in a
flashback
in the film adaptation of the half-bird
prince it's likely that the strange was
the father of rodolphus lestrange who
would later marry bellatrix
number 19. lily evans lily evans was a
muggle-born witch and harry potter's
mother
she was an impressive witch with a
particular talent in potions
making her one of slughorn's favorite
favorites
when voldemort attempted to murder her
and her family she went on to cast the
famous
sacrificial protection which saved
harry's life and ended voldemort
for a period of time number 20. lucius
malfoy
lucius malfoy was a pureblood wizard
that came from the famous
malfoy family he was the father of draco
malfoy and son of abraxis malfoy
who was a friend of slughorns it is
stated that during lucius's time at
school
he was exceptionally gifted at potions
earning the attention of horus slughorn
though lucius was a loyal death eater
for many years him and his family
eventually defected from the death
eaters
number 21. melinda bobbin melinda bobbin
was a british witch who attended
hogwarts at the same time as the trio
bobbin's family owned a large chain of
apothecaries
and for perhaps this reason alone she
was invited into the slug club
number 22 knot knot was a pure blood
wizard and one of the earliest death
eaters
the knot family were part of the sacred
28 the 28 pure blood british families
that were still
truly pure blood by the time the 1930s
ruled around
knott was likely a member of tom
riddle's gang and was a friend of
slughorn for many years
slughorn would later cut ties with knott
as knott would go on to do unthinkable
things in the name of the death eaters
number 23 regulus black regulus black
was a pureblood wizard
and member of the famous black family he
was the son of orion and warburger black
and younger brother of sirius black
regulus was a member of slytherin house
and would go on to become seeker for
their quidditch
team in the film adaptation of the
half-blood prince
slughorn points out a photo of him and
regulus to harry
number 24 severus snape severus snape
was a half-blood wizard
potion's master defense against the dark
arts professor
hogwarts headmaster and death eater
defector
snape was invited to join the slug club
because of his obvious talent in the art
of potion making
while a student at hogwarts snape
assumed the alias the half-blood prince
and wrote all sorts of tips and tricks
into his copy of advanced potion making
the same copy that harry would later
find number 25
tom riddle tom riddle goes by another
name
lord voldemort i think it is tom riddle
was
like harry one of slughorn's absolute
favorites
while a student at hogwarts riddle was a
very impressive student
who expressed an unparalleled ability to
learn there is one particular branch of
magic however
that riddle may have learned a little
bit too much about
it has been expressed that slughorn was
responsible for providing riddle with
information on horcruxes
which were instrumental in voldemort's
rise to power number 26
unknown name though we don't know the
name of this slug club member we know
that someone in slughorn's class of 67
would go on to become the minister of
magical transportation
number 27 wendy slinkert the last member
of horus's slug club is wendy slinkard
who was a british witch and author in
the film adaptation of the half-blood
prince
slinkett is shown in a photograph on
slughorn's wall
it's likely that slinger is related to
wilbur slinkard
who is the author of defensive magical
theory a book that teaches defensive
magic
in a secure risk-free way umbridge is a
known proponent of this book
and that concludes the entire list of
slug club members
were you surprised by anyone in this
list did i miss any
let me know down in the comment section
below as always like the video and
subscribe to the channel if you enjoy
the content
until next time you're a wizard harry
you